(upbeat music)
- I'm a dog.
Have you seen this?
I'm a dog, ah. (laughs)
This is crazy.
Ahh.
(barking)
(laughs)
- [Voiceover] Look at this dog.
Look at this dog.
Oh, another dog.
Another dog!
Oh, another dog!
Even another.
Oh my God, look at this cute squirrel.
Look at this squirrel.
A squirrel.
- Is this right?
Am I.
I can't tell if I'm doing this right.
Hey, am I.
Hello?
- [Voiceover] All right, eating clean.
Mmm.
Someone brought dumplings.
Wu ohhh.
Whoa oh.
Drinking water baby.
- What's up everybody.
Today's daily motivation
is to stay positive.
No matter what, you are worth it.
All right guys, let's go out
there and kick some butt.
♫ Rolling with my crew
♫ On a pair of 42 ♫
Walking.
(pop music)
♫ Girl you know
♫ You know I miss you girl
♫ You know I do man ♫
(cyring) Girl I miss you.
(upbeat music)